vor 50 Jahren endet die Geiselnahme der
israelischen Geiseln im Olympischen Dorf
mit einem Desaster auf dem Flughafen in
Fürstenfeldbruck
das war 1972 1977 entsteht ein Mythos
bei der Befreiung der Landshut durch die
GSG 9 ich habe den Kommandeur bei mir im
Studio den ich sehr herzlich begrüßte
Jerome Fuchs was ist das Wichtigere
Datum für Sie
sind beides ganz entscheidende Daten für
die GSG9 für mich persönlich ist es die
Befreiung der Landshut denn es ist bis
heute der bekannteste Einsatz der GSG9
auf den wir alle sehr stolz sind und
eröffnet uns bis heute auch Türen in die
Welt das was da in München passiert ist
aus der Sicht der Polizei und der
Behörden war desaströs und dieses
furchtbare Bild haben wir hier von den
Terroristen wir haben aber vor allen
Dingen auch das furchtbare Bild auf dem
Flughafen von Fürstenfeldbruck
das bedeutet alle Geiseln kommen ums
Leben und in dieser Nacht noch hat er
damalige Innenminister Genscher
einem ihrer Vorläufer dem Gründer quasi
der GSG9 general Wegener gesagt sie
müssen ein solche Truppe aufbauen das
erste was er gemacht hat ist ich muss da
Israel ich muss da lernen und das ist
für sie auch heute noch sehr
entscheidend ja absolut aus heutiger
Perspektive kann ich das sehr sehr gut
nachvollziehen
denn wir haben heute ein sehr guten
Draht eine sehr enge Kooperation und
Freundschaft mit Israel mit der
israelischen Spezialeinheit yamam mit
der wir sehr sehr gut zusammenarbeiten
ich denke aus historischer Sicht auch
damals war Israel führend im Bereich der
Spezialeinheiten und von daher auch sehr
schlüssig dass damals Herr Wegener nach
Israel gefahren ist und dort ja mit
großem diplomatischen Geschick Türen
geöffnet hat
man muss sich das vergegenwärtigen
in den 70er Jahren war das sicher noch
mal deutlich schwieriger als heute diese
entsprechenden Zugänge zu bekommen das
hat er geschafft und ja mit diesem
Know-how dass er aus Israel mitgebracht
hat hat er dann im Bundesgrenzschutz
eine neue Einheit aufgebaut mit
freiwilligen mit hoher Motivation ich
weiß das aus persönlichen Gesprächen mit
ihm er war bis ja kurz vor seinem Tod
noch sehr oft und sehr intensiv bei der
GSG9 und hat sich mit uns ausgetauscht
und
ja hat auch gerade über diese Zeit
berichtet und da viel mitgenommen wir
haben vor zehn Jahren ein Gespräch mit
ihm gemacht auch im Rahmen dieser
Sendung im Dialog persönlich da hat er
erzählt als er nach Israel kam das war
ja ganz kurz nach Fürstenfeldbruck
und sagte da muss ich jetzt lernen sind
ihm die ersten auch ein wichtiger Mann
für später Barak erst einmal ohne ein
Gruß entgegengetreten also er musste
sich das Vertrauen erwerben wie ist das
Verhältnis heute
also heute ist das ein Verhältnis auf
Augenhöhe
für mich persönlich ist das ich sage das
deutlich noch immer ein Geschenk dass
wir diesen Zugang zu Israel heute haben
mit einer
Kameradschaft einer Freundschaft die für
uns heute im Grunde normal ist aber man
muss sich das vergegenwärtigen welcher
Weg war es dorthin und insofern ich kann
das gut nachvollziehen dass Israel
zunächst sehr reserviert war als ja ein
deutscher Offizier des
Bundesgrenzschutzes ankam und um
Know-how zur Durchführung einer
geiselbefreiungsoperation gefragt hat
das ist auch mir persönlich jetzt bei
der Gedenkfeier in Fürstenfeldbruck noch
mal sehr deutlich geworden was das
damals für Israel bedeutet hat sie
hatten Unterstützung angeboten
sie standen bereit das wurde noch mal
sehr sehr deutlich durch die die
Opferfamilien durch Anke Spitze auch
in einem persönlichen Gespräch dass ich
mit ihr führen durfte
klar gemacht
der israelische Staatspräsident hat es
angesprochen also da war ja große großes
Unverständnis bis hin zur zur
Verzweiflung warum diese diese
angebotene Hilfe nicht angenommen wurde
weil man da natürlich bei den Israelis
viel viel weiter war wir kennen ja die
Bilder von den Polizisten in
Trainingsanzügen die gar nicht wussten
was sie da machen in im Olympiadorf
wegen einer hat dann auch mal erzählt
dass er
kurz nach seiner Rückkehr nach
Deutschland nachdem in Israel war
angerufen worden ist und man hat ihm
gesagt kommen Sie doch mal zu einer
Übung nach Israel und es ist
atemberaubend was damals passiert ist er
durfte mit den israelischen Kommandos
gemeinsam über Israel abspringen das ist
ja unfassbar wenn man sich das heute
vorstellt
ja also aus historischer Sicht auf jeden
Fall dass das damals schon gelungen ist
heute ist es für uns ja wie gesagt
eigentlich schon normal dass wir auf
dieser Ebene mit den Israelis heute
zusammenarbeiten zusammen trainieren
auch heute gemeinsam über der negerwüste
abspringen
das ganze aber auch in Deutschland
machen und ja umso mehr freut es mich
dass wir jetzt anlässlich des
50-jährigen
Gedenktages in Fürstenfeldbruck
einen gemeinsamen Fallschirmsprung
durchführen konnten mit den Kameraden
der yamam und im Grunde an genau der
Stelle gelandet sind an der 1972 ein
Hubschrauber des Bundesgrenzschutzes
ausbrannte und ja israelische Geiseln
darin ums Leben kam was war das für ein
Gefühl für Sie als jeder abgesprungen
sind ein ganz besonderes
unbeschreibliches Gefühl
es war und ist für mich einer meiner
bedeutendsten Tage in meiner aktiven
Laufbahn da übertreibe ich nicht wenn
ich das sage das war etwas was ganz ganz
besonderes
es geht ja jetzt nach 72 vor allen
Dingen der Blick auf 1977 da hat sich
mit der Erstürmung der Landshut die so
erfolgreich war so was wie so ein Mythos
der GSG9 entwickelt das war eine
erfolgreiche
Aktion und zwar war die so erfolgreich
dass sie heute in der Welt als eine der
besten Spezialtruppen gelten empfinden
sie das eigentlich als Belastung diesen
Mythos von der Landshut
also eine Belastung ist es nicht aber es
ist selbstverständlich eine eine
Verpflichtung
einer besonderen Erwartungshaltung
gerecht zu sehen hier jetzt gerade die
Geiseln nach der Befreiung in Frankfurt
als sie aus der Maschine steigen das war
ein unglaublicher Moment also bis heute
ist es nach wie vor der bekannteste
Einsatz der GSG 9 und selbstverständlich
ist der aktive Verband auch sehr sehr
stolz auf das was
unsere Kameraden der ersten Stunde dort
geleistet haben ein wirklich
großartiger Einsatzerfolg und wie sie
sagen ja bis heute
profitieren wir auch von diesem Einsatz
und eröffnet uns bis heute Türen aber
was mir auch wichtig ist eine G9 kann im
Jahr 2022 nicht auf diesen Einsatz
reduziert werden wir haben seit Gründung
über 2000 Einsätze erfolgreich
durchgeführt aber noch mal das ist bis
heute der
bekannteste Einsatz
das hätte auch schief gehen können wenn
man sich all das noch einmal durchliest
was bei dem bei der Befreiung der
Landshut passiert ist dann waren einige
Dinge standen quasi auf das Messers
Schneide
ja wobei das letztendlich ein Risiko ist
dass wir bei jeder Einsatzlage haben
sonst setzt man auch eine Spezialeinheit
nicht ein wenn ich jedes Risiko
ausschließen könnte dann gibt es keinen
Grund für unseren Einsatz aber in der
Tat da waren sicher viele
ja Möglichkeiten gegeben dass der
Einsatz anders hätte ausgehen können
aber die Kameraden haben damals alles
richtig gemacht sie haben jahrelang auf
diesen Einsatz hin trainiert und ja dann
auf den Punkt das abgerufen was ihr
trainiert haben und das war entsprechend
erfolgreich
generell wegen der Stolz neben seinen
GSG9 Beamten sehen wir hier
was für eine prägende Figur war er
ja er war und ist
unser Gründervater und
sicher ein sehr eine sehr charismatische
Führungspersönlichkeit damals schon wie
gesagt ich habe in selbst bis kurz vor
seinem Tod erlebt und und ja durfte
viele Gespräche mit Ihnen führen
ja hatte hat er eine Vision und er
wollte eine Einheit aufstellen die in
der Lage ist
ja mit sämtlichen hochkomplexen
geißelszenarien
zurechtzukommen die lösen zu können
ein weiteres München oder
Fürstenfeldbruck 72 für alle Zeiten zu
verhindern
sie sind augenblicklich der Kommandeur
was können Sie
ja der Anspruch ist der gleiche denke
ich heute wir in den 70er Jahren war wir
sind dafür da besonders schwierige
komplexe Einsatzszenarien zu lösen und
das für die unterschiedlichsten Behörden
ob das im eigenen Bereich der
Bundespolizei
Unterstützungsleistungen sind die wir
geben in komplexen Verfahren für das
Bundeskriminalamt im Bereich von
terrorismusverfahren
rechts Linksextremismus
im Bereich von der organisierten
Kriminalität werden wir in ja komplexen
lagen eingesetzt also es ist ein sehr
sehr breites Spektrum dass wir heute
anbieten für die unterschiedlichsten
Behörden
wir bekommen das ja als
Bürger nur so peripher mit also wir
wissen da war bei dem Einsatz auch die
GSG neuen beteiligt dann wissen wir das
war nicht so ganz ohne da waren sie dann
dabei aber es gibt den umgekehrten Fall
es gibt immer wieder die Diskussion
darüber was ist mit den Geiseln und mit
der Geisel und vor allen Dingen mit den
Entführern im Fall Gladbeck passiert da
ist an der Landesgrenze von
Nordrhein-Westfalen nach Rheinland-Pfalz
ein Zugriff erfolgt damals von sek sie
sollen dabei
bereit gestanden haben die GSG 9 sie
sind aber nicht eingesetzt worden weil
der damalige Innenminister Schnoor
gesagt hat offenbar ich will dass die
Sek das SEK jetzt eingesetzt wird wie
weit haben sie heute noch mit solchen
politischen Interessen zu tun
also ich denke für die gesamte deutsche
Polizei
war Gladbeck ein einschneidendes
Erlebnis und
es sind Strukturen verändert worden nach
diesem Einsatz und ich bin mir sicher
dass so etwas heute anders laufen würde
und wir sind in guter Kooperation mit
allen Bundesländern und können diese
Bundesländer unterstützen wir haben
erheblich eine erhebliche Steigerung der
Einsatzzahlen die wir mittlerweile für
die Bundesländer durchführen und ja aus
meiner Sicht eine sehr sehr gute
Entwicklung man man muss gemeinsam
Einsätze fahren es muss Vertrauen
aufgebaut werden
um dann auch in solche besonderen Lagen
nachher auch zum Einsatz zu kommen wenn
man sich so ein bisschen die
biografischen Notizen von General
Wegener anschaut dann ist das am Anfang
schon mal das Problem gewesen auch
damals hat er immer wieder mal
Ärger gehabt mit dem Innenminister
Schnur der gesagt hat wir brauchen diese
GSG9 eigentlich nicht wir haben eine
ganz tolle eigene Einsatztruppe
ist das eine heute förderliche
Konkurrenz unter den Spezialgruppen also
ob das mobiles Einsatzkommando sek oder
GSG9 ist oder gibt es da immer noch naja
ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten im
Einzelfall also mir gefällt schon der
Begriff Konkurrenz in diesem
Zusammenhang nicht im Sport ja oder wenn
man sich in Leistungsvergleichen misst
dann ja in Einsatzlagen
ist das aus meiner Sicht der falsche
Ansatz damit im konkurrenzgedanken dran
zu gehen sondern da sollte es darum
gehen sich gegenseitig zu ergänzen
den Geiseln wird das völlig
unverständlich sein wenn sie nachher
erfahren dass irgendetwas schief
gegangen ist weil verschiedene Einheiten
nicht miteinander konnten also da ist es
an uns aufeinander zuzugehen und ja da
kann eine GSG9 eine Menge anbieten und
wie gesagt wir sind da die letzten Jahre
in sehr sehr guten Weg gegangen
gemeinsam mit den Bundesländern ohnehin
mit dem Bundeskriminalamt
und insofern glaube ich haben da alle
aus der Geschichte sehr viel gelernt was
haben sie gelernt aus dem was in Bad
Kleinen passiert ist dort habt es viele
Gerüchte um diesen Einsatz gegeben da
ging es um den Terroristen Grams der bei
diesem Einsatz gestorben ist
man hat immer wieder Untersuchungen
durchgeführt ist das möglicherweise eine
ein Fehler der GSG9 gewesen hat er sich
wirklich tatsächlich selber erschossen
bei diesem Einsatz inwieweit hat sie
dieses Thema berührt also es berührt
mich bis heute und zwar in erster Linie
da wir unseren Kameraden Michael
nefzeller in diesem Einsatz verloren
haben und die Vorwürfe
denen sich der Verband die GSG9
ausgesetzt war darauf sprechen Sie an
die waren gravierend das ging ja bis hin
zu er ist erschossen worden von der GSG9
richtig also das waren heftigste
Vorwürfe und es war ein langer
schwieriger Prozess diese Vorwürfe zu
entkräften und zu widerlegen was
gelungen ist aber es war sehr sehr
schwierig
eine Lehre die wir aus diesem Einsatz
gezogen haben ist dass wir tatsächlich
seitdem jeden einsatzvideografieren denn
die GSG9 durchführt
um ja das
rechtmäßige saubere Vorgehen unser
Einsatzkräfte auch beweisen zu können
wenn es der Fall sein sollte
das war damals noch anders gewesen und
ja
ich denke das war eine eine notwendige
Konsequenz die aus diesem Einsatz
gezogen wurde das was Sie brauchen sind
keine Spitzensportler das sind auch
keine super schützen aber sie brauchen
alle Mixtur aus allem und das auch noch
in einer besonderen Struktur sie haben
keinen militärisches Befehl und
gehorsamsystem das müssen sie noch mal
erklären
nein ein rein militärisches Befehl und
gehorsamsystem haben wir nicht das kann
auch eigentlich gar nicht funktionieren
so kann man auch keine Spezialeinheit
führen sondern
wir arbeiten mit der sogenannten
Auftragstaktik das heißt als
Führungskraft gebe ich einen klar
definierten Auftrag vor das wie das
heißt wie der Auftrag dann abgearbeitet
wird da setze ich großes Vertrauen in
die Einsatzkräfte in die Führungskräfte
vor Ort die dann auch vor Ort
entscheiden auch das übrigens
ja eine Art zu führen die Herr Wegener
schon sehr früh in der GSG9
implementiert hat die sich durch die
ganzen Jahrzehnte durchgezogen hat
Auftragstaktik und das Führen vor Ort
das heißt Entscheidungen soll nicht
irgendwo abgesetzt am grünen Tisch
getroffen werden sondern sie sollen vor
Ort getroffen werden durch die Kräfte
die vor Ort eingesetzt werden und die
Führung sollte die Kräfte
transportbestmöglich unterstützen zu
Anfang bei der Gründung der GSG9 ging es
ja vor allen Dingen erst einmal darum
die messbaren Ergebnisse sich anzugucken
ist der schnell genug in bestimmten
Situationen reagiert der richtig
schießt der gut genug und so weiter und
so weiter und dann kam plötzlich ein
psychologischer Moment dazu weil man
gemerkt hat das ist zu wenig dieses
können da brauchen wir noch mehr also
wir brauchen eigentlich auch ausgereifte
Persönlichkeiten wie werden die heute
ausgesucht also da nehmen wir uns sehr
viel Zeit für die Personalauswahl und
wie Sie richtig sagen das Spielen
Psychologen eine wichtige Rolle aber
nicht nur Psychologen sondern auch
unsere eigenen Führungskräfte
unsere Ausbilder wir bilden da ein
gemischtes Team wir nehmen uns sehr viel
Zeit für die Bewerber denn das ist ja
der Schlüssel zum Erfolg sich da
wirklich gründlich mit dem Bewerber zu
beschäftigen und ihm auch wenn es nicht
geklappt hat ein deutliches Feedback zu
geben woran erarbeiten muss und dann
freuen wir uns sehr wenn er es nochmal
versucht
das Wichtigste für uns ist der ist der
Charakter die Einstellung
der Teamgedanke den erleben muss und ja
er muss auch eine gute körperliche
Leistungsfähigkeit mitbringen aber das
haben Sie richtig angesprochen das ist
nicht der absolute Schwerpunkt wie weit
sind Frauen bei ihnen tätig jetzt stelle
ich mir vor auch wenn Sie jetzt das ein
bisschen relativieren sagen also
körperlichen Voraussetzungen sind jetzt
nicht das einzige sondern sind ein
wichtiger Teil wie weit können Frauen
sich bewerben bzw welche Chancen haben
die und in welchen ja Funktionen können
Sie tätig werden
also grundsätzlich kann sich eine Frau
bei uns für jede Tätigkeit in der GSG9
bewerben sowohl im Einsatz
unterstützenden Bereich als auch für die
Einsatzeinheit tatsächlich haben wir
bisher zum Glück immer mehr Frauen in
den Einsatz unterstützenden Bereichen im
technischen Bereichen in der
einsatzmedizin
bisher noch nicht in der Einsatzeinheit
aber ich glaube wir sind
es ist ja wir machen tatsächlich bei den
körperlichen Anforderungen keinerlei
Unterschiede das heißt die Frauen müssen
absolut die gleichen körperlichen
Leistungen im Testverfahren erbringen
wie die Männer und das ist für die
Einsatzeinheit schon eine relativ hohe
Hürde so dass wir leider in den letzten
Jahren für die Einsatzeinheit keine
Bewerberin hatten aber in der Tat für
die Einsatz unterstützende Bereiche wird
es mehr was sehr freut man schadet bei
ihnen aus dem Dienst mit 45 glaube ich
aus
jetzt gibt es auch hin und wieder mal
Hinweise ja also GSG9 alleine durchs
Training sind Menschen die im
Zweifelsfall sehr viel früher aufhören
müssen weil da einfach eine enorme
Belastung auf gerade auch die
körperliche Verfassung zukommt ist das
tatsächlich ein ich kann ja nicht sagen
Job an einen Beruf eine
Berufung wie sie es auch verkörpern die
bedeutet dass man immer wieder an die
Grenze auf der körperlichen Fähigkeiten
gehen muss
also in der Einsatzeinheit ist das in
der Tat so und das ist richtig da ist
für uns 45 die Altersgrenze
in der ja Angehörige der Einsatzeinheit
diese dann auch verlassen müssen aber
wir versuchen selbstverständlich
möglichst viele Angehörige der
Einsatzeinheiten in andere Bereiche der
GSG9 zu übernehmen in die Bereiche der
Fortbildung in Bereiche der Einsatz
Unterstützung um einfach das Know-how
nicht zu verlieren und
ja so für den Verband auch zu zu
bewahren aber klar ist auch eine GSG9
darf nicht überaltern und
wir sind auch immer
sehr bestrebt möglichst viele Bewerber
für uns zu bekommen jetzt hat sie das ja
wahrscheinlich auch fasziniert als sie
sich beworben haben davon gehe ich mal
aus da ist auch so ein bisschen
wahrscheinlich Elite Gedanken wie weit
passende Elite sein und wie weit nicht
ja es darf so weit Elite sein solange
man sich nicht sag mal über andere
Einheiten stellt ja oder meint jetzt man
wäre etwas besseres dann driftet das ab
aber ich denke mit einem gesunden
Leistungsgedanken mit einer hohen
intrinsischen Motivation die man
mitbringt mit einer einer hohen
Leistungsbereitschaft etwas besonderes
machen zu wollen
wir würden das nie von uns selbst sagen
Elite zu sein wenn dann aber bei
Einheiten die uns anfordern für die wir
ein Einsatz machen ein guter Eindruck
bleibt und wir rückgespiegelt bekommen
Mensch
professionell abgearbeitet ihr habt uns
toll unterstützt ja dann ist das das Lob
was wir was wir gerne hören aber nicht
was wir uns selbst geben würden trotzdem
sind aus dem Elite Bewusstsein aus dem
Gedanken aus auch Dinge passiert beim
SEK beim
Einsatzkommando beim KSK also der
Spezialtruppe der Bundeswehr da gab es
rechtsradikale Äußerungen Exzesse etc da
sind sie bisher eigentlich völlig von
verschont geblieben was ist da passiert
ist das nicht aus dem Elite Gedanken
heraus doch passiert
also vielleicht sprechen wir besser
darüber warum es bei uns nicht passiert
ist dass wir mit tatsächlich lieber denn
ich zeige da ungern mit dem mit dem
Finger auf Andere
wir haben über die Personalauswahl
gesprochen das ist der erste Schritt den
wir gehen wo wir uns wirklich viel Zeit
nehmen mit der charakterlichen
Einstellung desjenigen der sich zu uns
bewirbt zu beschäftigen und
ein zweiter
wesentlicher Aspekt auf den ich auch
viel Wert lege auch bei meinen
Führungskräften ist zu sensibilisieren
gerade für dieses Thema
rechter Tendenzen
immer wieder das Thema auch auch wach
halten darüber zu sprechen das zu
sensibilisieren
ja und ich denke so kann man auch
verhindern dass solche Tendenzen im
Verband entstehen jetzt weiß ich nicht
wie die anderen Einheiten das gemacht
haben aber das ist unser Weg und ja wir
hatten keine Vorfälle worüber ich sehr
sehr froh bin aber ich glaube das ist
ein Thema dass man immer wach halten aus
an dem man auch immer
dranbleiben muss und das versuche ich
mit meinen Führungskräften und ja das
auch selbstverständlich in enger
Abstimmung mit der
Bundespolizeidirektion 11 der wir ja
nachgeordnet sind da ist das auch ein
Schwerpunkt des behördenleiters
sie selber waren sicherlich fasziniert
von dem Gedanken zur GSG9 zu kommen
hat sich das sozusagen bei ihnen erfüllt
sie sind Kommandeur also sozusagen die
höchste Ebene
[Musik]
wie stark ist das persönlich bei Ihnen
dieses Gefühl
der GSG 9 vorzustehen oder mit den
Kameraden zusammen die GSG9 zu bilden
was ist das für ein emotionales Gefühl
also als ich 1997 zur GSG9 gekommen bin
da war es nie das Ziel irgendwie die die
Hierarchie besonders weit nach oben zu
klettern da war es erstmal die
Motivation zu dieser es zu dieser
Einheit zu schaffen die Ausbildung zu
schaffen dabei zu sein interessanter
Einsätze zu machen ja das ganze hat sich
dann tatsächlich so im Laufe der Jahre
so einfach ist vielleicht klingt ergeben
es ist schon gekonnt haben
wann natürlich versucht man die
entsprechende Leistung zu bringen und
wenn das an anderer Stelle dann auch
erkannt wird dann geht man auch die
entsprechenden Schritte
es ist bis heute eine eine riesen Ehre
für mich und auch eine eine riesengroße
Verpflichtung das vernünftig und gut zu
machen also sie haben anfangs gefragt ja
ist das eine Belastung oder oder würde
und irgendwo ja schwingt schon eine eine
große
Verpflichtung mit den den Verband
ja sauber zu führen und
ja letztlich werden wir an Einsatz
Erfolgen gemessen und
auch daran immer alle Kameraden auch
heil als den Einsätzen wieder
zurückzubringen diese Einsätze sind wir
haben ja eben schon mal angedeutet auch
schon in Bereichen wo sie mit anderen
Spezialtruppen zusammenarbeiten da gibt
es Einsätze zum Beispiel gegen die
klaren Kriminalität
da werden sie immer wieder zusätzlich
angefordert ist das ein Spektrum dessen
was die GSG9 in Zukunft
weiter noch sozusagen beschäftigen wird
denn wir haben zurzeit zumindest keine
starke islamistische Terrorgefahr oder
zumindest ist sie nicht bekannt wir
wissen ja nicht was die Geheimdienste
oder sie wissen es vielleicht aber was
die Geheimdienste für Erkenntnisse haben
das heißt wo ist das Spektrum der GSG9
in Zukunft als ich denke das Spektrum
ist neben der Terrorismusbekämpfung in
allen Feldern der Bekämpfung der
organisierten Kriminalität sie sprechen
Clan Kriminalität an ja das ist ein ein
Feld aber auch ja in sämtlichen anderen
Bereichen der der UK ob das ja
Rauschgiftkriminalität ist Waffenhandel
schleuserkriminalität
all das sind Felder die uns auch in
Zukunft intensiv beschäftigen werden und
ja da wollen wir mit der GSG9 auch
künftig die entsprechenden Antworten
liefern
man sagt ja aus dem Bereich der
kriminellen es gibt so einen Fall zum
Beispiel das clanführers Miri sobald
GSG9 neben der SEK auftaucht oder
Immobilien Einsatzkommando dann wird es
ernst dann wird es auch für die
Clan-Mitglieder ernst
ist das eine Wirkung die sie auch
umgekehrt verspüren das heißt wir haben
schon den Eindruck dass auch gerade die
organisierte Kriminalität mit großer
Gewalt vorgeht
zunehmender Gewalt
ja in der Tat
wobei diese Gewalt sich jetzt weniger
gegen uns richtet wir versuchen ja
möglichst gewaltfrei die Einsätze
durchzuführen einfach durch ein
Überraschungsmoment so schnell auch zu
sein um überhaupt erst keine Gewalt
einsetzen zu müssen
aber ja
selbstverständlich
rechnen wir mit dem entsprechenden
gegenüber und haben auch
Erkenntnisse über die Gewaltbereitschaft
über die Bewaffnung und insofern gehen
wir da auch immer vom vom Schlimmsten
aus und bereiten uns entsprechend vor
die feiern in diesem Jahr das Jubiläum
[Musik]
die GSG 9 wird ein Kommando immer sagen
ist ja wichtiger als je zuvor ist das so
ja in der Tat also wenn sie sich allein
die Einsatzzahlen der letzten Jahre oder
auch insbesondere diesen Jahres
anschauen dann werden wir immer mehr
angefordert wir sind im Moment bei einem
Stand den wir so vorher
noch nicht hatten also das ist sie nicht
dann nehme ich mal an da halte ich mich
jetzt etwas bedeckt aber es ist deutlich
angestiegen die die Anzahl der
Anforderungen für uns und ja insofern
ist das ja ein guter Beweis dass wir
gebraucht werden dass man auf uns zählt
und ja auch mit unserer Leistung rechnet
jerem Fuchs ganz herzlichen Dank dass
Sie bei mir waren danke schön vielen
Dank
[Musik]